[Music]
all right it is big bang theory times go
to sheldon in bellingham washington hey
sheldon what's going on
hey there dr john man it's uh
good to talk to you i really appreciate
your time better to talk to you you
never hear big bang theory jokes do you
never listen man my last name rhymes
with like a processed lunch meat i'm
with you
we're gonna persevere through this we'll
get through it so what's up brother how
can i help me okay
oh man first of all my heart goes out to
great that grace that's uh that's hard
to hear yeah it's a tough tough tough
situation man tough tough tough yeah
yeah so what's up in your world man
so my wife and i we're foster parents um
hold on can we stop and celebrate you
guys what got you into fostering
uh i mean early on my wife wanted to do
it before we got married and i wanted to
adopt and so we met halfway with
fostering to start with
that's so good why are we doing this
because my wife wanted to but you did
too so good for you well man what a gift
you're putting out in the world i'm
grateful for you so what's up y'all are
fostering um
yeah we're fostering um got a little one
with us right now we've had several uh
short term and then another long term
one that's back with family now and
got a little one with us now that's
about 13 months old picked her up from
the hospital um
it's just you know heartbreaking to see
the whole family dynamic yeah uh but i'm
smiling right now i'm so glad y'all were
there to pick her up that's incredible
she's pretty incredible i tell you what
she is uh
yeah i don't know never been a big one
for little kids but my goodness i didn't
know that little kids could be that much
fun dude they will take your soul and
spirit from you man it's it's incredible
yeah it's awesome yeah yeah so what's up
um
so the one parent has basically
disappeared made it very clear to social
workers everybody my legal obligations
are done i want nothing to do okay other
family member um
is living it's a very complicated
scenario living with somebody that is
filing for custody on their behalf
and that is allowing this individual to
not really go through any of the steps
to get their proper custody
and so what that means is if
the child goes into
this
person's care
then
this family member could just take the
kid there's no repercussions there's no
follow-ups no nothing the kid just
disappears
and
yeah as a foster parent you're powerless
yeah man
so i have heard of this attempted before
um
several of my close mentors were
um
attorneys or counselors in this system
i've heard of that attempted before i
haven't heard it be successful
it it might be whoops i just squeaked my
microphone here i've i've
i've heard that attempted i've never
heard it be successful because the
person filing for custody if they're
just some random boyfriend or just some
random girlfriend
they have to prove a connection
and a dating relationship often doesn't
provide that connection
and yeah usually i see it some
downstream relative will pop out of
nowhere and say i'll step in but i've
heard this attempted but i haven't heard
it be successful have you heard that be
successful in your area
yeah and part of the complication is
this person filing for custody has the
half siblings these six half-siblings of
this child in their care uh well then
hey that's i'm wrong there's a hundred
percent chance they're going to get
custody then
yeah and dad is not even fully blood to
these other kids okay another yeah it's
doesn't matter if
if there's half siblings there then the
court will sign that over in heartbeat
and they will call that a family
reunification and they will move on to
the next case on their overloaded docket
of people who refuse to take
responsibility for their children which
is just heartbreaking
so
yeah i mean she'll be the seventh kid
under 12. yep in that home yeah
here's uh
i'm just gonna tell you the truth okay
when you are in foster parenting and i'm
telling this you already know this
you are a bridge
and you help
hold suspended children
while the adults in their life who have
are not acting like adults figure out
what they're going to do
and
the word when anyone says i'm a foster
parent the first or should i be a foster
parent the first thing i ask them is can
you handle heartbreak
because that is the nature of foster
care
it's heartbreaking even in the best of
situations you've been living with this
little baby and holding her and taking
care of her and feeding her and laughing
with her and getting to know her weird
little cute 13 month old personality
and even in the greatest of situations
it's heartbreaking to hand her back
right
yeah and
in these situations
man
it's devastating
especially because you can't control the
outcome
so my challenge to you brother is to put
that stuff down because you can't do
anything about it
and you're going to make yourself crazy
trying to solve problems that you can't
solve
gotcha
that sucks doesn't it
yeah yeah really enough
and the real challenge here is
can you keep your heart open enough
to go level another little kid
and i want to tell you as a foster
parent how many foster kids have you had
uh she's a second long-term placement
but we've had probably
20 kids in our home in the last two
years so you know this better than i do
man
of course you do
but you know every time it's that your
heart fills up and then man it feels
like it's had the air taken out of it
right
yep is this one is this one this one
feels like it's uniquely painful for you
yeah i mean it was directly following
the placement of the last child and i
mean had a couple miscarriages and a lot
of failed adoption attempts privately
yep how are you and your wife doing
she wants a baby yeah
and you want to do whatever it takes to
get her one huh
i mean short of stealing a kid
hey man if you got to do what you got to
do brother i'm just kidding don't do
that please don't
when's the last time you all sat down
and looked at each other and made sure
y'all are still on the same page
oh two weeks ago and then the next day
we had a call about a possible adoption
that they needed a placement for
immediately and then it fell through due
to paperwork of course
yep yep we've had
numerous issues of that nature yeah
so here's what's here's here's what i
need you to do man
number one
you're in love with a tiny little baby
girl
and you took her home for the hospital
and you've loved her
and
whatever her whatever her destiny looks
like it's going to be different
positively because you and your wife
stepped into a gap that her parents
didn't provide
and as a member of
your community and her community i'm so
grateful for you guys and she is too
and there's some people gaming the
system
doing ender rounds on the system
and right now there's nothing you can do
about that you can get a lawyer and try
to fight it i guess i can't imagine
you'd be successful because you're
giving a shot yeah
as a foster parent you have no legal
representation right
and so i tell you is to have a grieving
process with your wife where y'all can
walk through this and
you also know the grief wrapped up here
man is bigger than just this little baby
girl going into a really tough
tough situation it also is yet another
opportunity for me and my wife to have a
family and what we think is gonna be our
picture of a family and we're not going
to do that
and i couldn't
xyz and she could in xyz and there's so
much guilt here's what happens these
bricks in this backpack end up weighing
down your marriage to the point that it
makes it hard to keep driving and that's
why i want you guys to check in and
always keep checking in and always keep
checking in
because you all are firefighters now and
you got to make sure each other are
breathing
because y'all are playing you all are
helping people in the most dire
situations but your relationship can can
you know where the where the scars are
those those interactions right
yeah yeah
if you can um i don't know what work
looks like i would love to see you guys
get away for a weekend and just control
delete and reset
and i mean that's
yeah that's pretty easy i have a pretty
great work schedule i'd love to see all
uh you've heard me say this a hundred
times i'll say 100 times more
um
every time this happens
it's just like the twin towers falling
you can't take all that glass and dust
and steel and rebuild those same two
towers you got to excavate the whole
thing and build something else new and
create something beautiful and say all
right here we go again
i'd love to see all exhale and say
where are we what's it gonna look like
tomorrow let's go back in two weeks it's
gonna come up and
you're not failing anybody if you all
take a break
at some point you gotta put on your
oxygen mask first brother
and i know it feels like well if we take
a break that could be the day of the
call that could be the y'all can do that
until you make each other crazy
and it may be time for a break 20 kids
22 kids and a couple of hard heart
breaks and some miscarriages in the last
24 months is a lot of trauma
yeah
well yeah i mean miscarriages were
before the
24 months that hasn't these guitars
either um
yeah go for it
do you have any advice on connecting
with this parent or the
possible person that would be taking
placement of the child
i always um slade sullivan is one of my
most one of the most important men i've
ever known and they have been foster
parents and adoptive parents
and they
were the ones that
him and his wife taught me about the
importance of reaching out to family
members
sometimes it's a no-go
but sometimes um the parents were really
open to
here's how to be a good mom is that to
be a good dad here's what this baby
loves
and so being proactive and not being not
thinking i'm the best but i've loved
this little baby right now and we could
teach you guys they may say you know
what y'all screw off we don't need you
that's our kid
or they may say oh that'd be incredible
we would love that
and so
again you're setting yourself up from a
heartbreak for sure
but i am always
always going to lean into that and i
watched um
slade and his wife do that and it was it
was extraordinary they you know slade's
wife would go to coffee with these moms
and talk about parenting and what love
looks like and
um really remarkable things and so yeah
i if if you have the stomach for that in
the heart for that i i think that would
be a remarkable thing again this is all
for that little baby right all for that
yeah
and you may get rejected again right so
what are you going to do
um yeah
yeah and it may be time for a break i'm
not going to speak into your marriage
but i do i definitely think it's time
for y'all to step away and say
who where are we
and you to make sure you look her in the
eye and hold
both sides of her face and let her know
i love you and i'm in this with you
what's tomorrow going to look like
and she needs to say the same thing to
you too thank you so much for loving
that little baby girl for loving your
wife for loving those kids
oh foster parents y'all are heroes
heroes heroes heroes heroes incredible
incredible incredible
man oh man a man
man oh man a man
kelly i don't tell you enough
you and your husband are good people too
you help me down this road also
your husband's really great on multiple
accounts but
i even i have to agree with that one yes
as someone who only has to deal with a
few hours of kelly a day
whoa just kidding he's a lucky man
do you have anything you can pass along
with sheldon i mean you've walked this
walk
not no because we have it in the same
aspect if we never had to deal with
birth parents yeah or anything like that
um
it's hard huh yeah the only thing i can
say is because i ran the adoption
ministry in foster administrator our
church for a while is
that
given the situation they're going into
there's a distinct possibility this
child's coming back out again yeah
and
be there
one of our friends this happened
probably 12 times that the child came
out over a number of years and every
time they took
took her until finally the mother said i
can't do it anymore
and they now have adopted her
and
and they have a relationship with the
mother too
so as hard as that is every time they
had to leave
but every time and they knew she was
going to come back out
again back into the system and they just
picked her up and took her back every
time
keep those doors open huh yeah so you
can do it so hard and then you know like
you said be the one that stands in that
gap for that parent or for that baby
because
maybe they grow up with two great
families yeah exactly or they always
have a picture of there's a point when a
teenager recognizes
it doesn't hap my parents whoa right
even in the best case scenarios parents
or kids recognize that
but there may be that moment when the
kid goes wait a minute that's what this
could look like right and a foster
parent is who has stuck with a kid over
over a number of years gives them a
picture of what parenting and love and
showing up and connection looks like not
just i mean it's just worth its weight
in gold right